[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
und einfaches suppen rezept aus meiner
kindheit köpfte den ball einfach super
mit kleinen frikadellen mit kleinen
bällchen und ich mach die suppe im
prinzip so wie meine mama selber für uns
gemacht hat mit dem unterschied dass ich
sie etwas würziger macht meine mama hat
immer die suppe ohne zwiebeln oder
knoblauch gemacht denn wir machen das
als kind einfach nicht also ich wollte
überhaupt keine zwiebel beißen und auch
keinen knoblauch beißen aber jetzt sowie
erwachsenenalter schmeckt natürlich
besser wenn sie etwas witziger ist und
wenig die zwiebel und knoblauch fein
genug macht merken ist die kinder
afghanische männer lieben die suppe sie
essen sie total gerne super schnell
zubereitet vor allem habe ich
hackfleisch auch gerne immer im
gefrierschrank das heißt kann die suppe
immer zu bereiten und ihr braucht dafür
nur wenige zutaten
ich habe jetzt 250 gramm hackfleisch vom
rind eine zwiebel und eine knoblauchzehe
etwas salz und pfeffer 100 gramm mehl
hier habe ich dann noch 30 gramm butter
etwas wasser natürlich salz und pfeffer
ich nehme mir noch eine karotte
zitronensaft und suppen nudeln
für mich ist jetzt bisschen
außergewöhnlich die zutaten vorab zu
messen denn suppen rezepte die mache ich
halt immer nach gefühl dass ich meiner
mama immer gemacht hat aber für euch
mäßig natürlich alles ab als ich nehme
jetzt einfach eine feine küche nwri
bleibt die knoblauchzehe und auch die
zwiebel fein so merkt man keine stücke
wie können sie auch kurz in den mixer
zerkleinern
[Musik]
für die zwiebel war dir ein bisschen zu
klein da nehme ich jetzt die hier
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier noch salz und pfeffer
dazu und dann einfach ganz kurz
verkneten muss jetzt meine kleine
helferin de la ihr wollt mir helfen
ja hab mich veräppelt mit die er
eigentlich helfen
naja jetzt nämlich das mehl das kommt
hier in einen teller
jetzt kommt ihr lauter kleine
hackbällchen so etwa 1 cm groß und wälzt
sie dann im mail
deswegen gebe ich dir hier in so einem
teller rein dann kann ich nämlich gleich
schütteln und dann sind sie schon
komplett bedeckt
[Musik]
wenn die fleischbällchen dann soweit
sind könnt ihr hier schon heute in einem
großen topf erwärmen unternimmt jetzt
entweder einen gusseisernen topf oder
einem beschichteten damit die haft
welchen aber nicht mehr anbrennen und
ankleben oder nehmt einfach ein bisschen
mehr wenn ihren spaß gehabt
[Musik]
es kommen hier die welschen rein und
werden rund herum muss durch
angebrachten je nachdem wie viel fett
oder hackfleisch hat kann sein dass wir
jetzt noch ein bisschen mutter braucht
oder es reicht dann eben schon von der
fed menge her denn die fleischbällchen
verlieren ja auch gleichgesinnte das
mehl sich aber jetzt so ein bisschen ab
dass überschüssige ich merke bei mir ich
brauche noch ein bisschen fett daher
gebe ich nur futter dazu
dann kann ich schon mal die karotten
schälen
jetzt den topf verschwenken nicht so
sehr rührend damit die welt schon aber
nicht zerstört werden
es dauert etwa 45 minuten bis sie schön
knusprig sind
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die bildschirm kurz raus
ok ich brauche noch mal ein bisschen
butter ich habe ich hab da so ein butter
gefäß was ich immer direkt auf abruf
hier bereit stelle ich brauche jetzt
nämlich noch ein bisschen butter für
eine mehlschwitze dann kommt jetzt hier
mehr dazu
ca 2 esslöffel ich schreibe euch im
rezept einfach eine etwas kleinere menge
denn das so genau aufgeht dann habt ihr
für mich perfekt für die suppe und
nichts übrig anschwitzen
eine minute noch mal einfach so bis so
eine hellbraune farbe bekommt dann
direkt mit wasser ablöschen und schön
aufkochen lassen
zum aufkochen gebe es jetzt einfach kurz
im deckel drauf
das geht nämlich schneller und ich kann
in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
karotte raspeln
die mache ich einfach hier mit dazu
einfach in social and stifte nicht zu
fein
[Musik]
ihr könnt auch eine größere schale
nehmen sind wir immer
und dann immer den rest der halter damit
eure finger vein bleiben
als nächstes jetzt mit salz und pfeffer
abschmecken
dann die sub nudeln dazu wir brauchen
jetzt nämlich am längsten und bei der
space ganz ganz ganz wichtig die zitrone
die suppe ist nämlich so ein bisschen
säuerlich 40 denkt vielleicht
ungewöhnlich voll
überall zitronensaft verteilt und
wirklich mit der zitrone auch nicht
sparen okay das ist jetzt eine große
zitrone daher nur drei viertel der
zitrone der rest lang ist auch hier und
jetzt gebe ich hier einfach noch die
hackbällchen und die karotten mit dazu
lasst die suppe noch für etwa zehn
minuten etwa könnten oder so lange bis
eben die nudeln gar sind
und dann hab ich alles drin
brakel verkosten
[Musik]
jetzt können wir die suppe probieren ja
und wie sich eine meiner absoluten
absoluten lieblings suchen
es gibt nicht viele suchen die ich mag
obwohl es wie immer aber erst mag ich
sie nicht und es ist ja aber wenn ich
sagte es gibt halt super dass die kinder
die kinder in den nächsten folgen zu
jeden tag etwas aufgeregt und ich find
auch also ich habe das von daheim so
gelernt und bei euch zu hause war es
genauso das weiß ich weil dann aber auch
suppen lebt ja super gibt es bei uns
weil man aber jeden tag weil die suppe
einfach den magen aufwärmt und ist
vorbereitet auf sehr flüssig ja und
bereitet sich halt aufs essen vorstand
nicht so viel also na du es schon
sättigungsgefühl da ja und ich finde es
ging ja wirklich braucht ganz sicher die
sorge die suppe auch nicht weiß wo so
nicht gegessen ich will jetzt einfach
gerne so nach und nach ein paar socken
rezepte einfach machen weil ich finde zu
jedem menü zu jedem hauptgericht gehört
einfach eine super truppe und es ist
wirklich günstig da kannst super und
brot ging ja da hast du auch wirklich
viel geld gespart und es ist wirklich
eine vollwertige mahlzeit und dies so
leicht säuerlich ich würde jetzt noch
chili drauf machen aber dass die kinder
an es muss halt ohne jenni dieses
säuerliche so genial und die karotten
haben wie kann ich einen auch leicht
realisieren gut natürlich geben wir die
fleischbällchen den geschmack aber was
ich mir kann ja auch wieder abziehen
geworden die frage was ich machen wollte
und mit all auf der iss werden wir
gemüsereste haben auch mal salat zum
beispiel und irgendwie ist keiner gern
salat vom vortag weil da so matschig
wird dann packen wir das einfach in der
pfanne an ganz lange und dann wird
studiert und dann kann ja einfach gleich
so weitermachen und dann hohes sowie
hackbällchen habe so schmerzen
haferflocken das richtig genial begeht
für diese suppe wird euch jeder lieben
es wird ein bisschen salz und ticker
aber sonst absicht weil ich mache ja
selbst also mehr salz aber auch nicht
also wo wir jetzt gerne aus ihr könnt ja
mal schreiben ob ihr gerne
somit wird er nicht ob ich mehr rezepte
dazu machen soll
und vielleicht auch was eure lieblings
so fair ist wenn ihre lieblingssuppe
abschreibt auch gerne rein wird dann
noch mal wirklich so eine tonne suppen
strecke also bis zum nächsten mal und
guten appetit
ein hoch auf die suche übrigens adelt
noch ganz kurz mit der türkei gibt es
einfach nur restaurants gorbatschow nur
ist es genial einfaches ganzes daneben
muss nur suppen gibt und nicht einfach
eine suppe und die wärmt sich auf und
muss ja nicht nur uns recht sein
hier könntest auch klein machen sagt
menschen und natürlich nicht so genau
mach's gut du jetzt noch was
ja es ist so cool ist und dazu ich habe
doch gerade einpacken nicht holst du
machst die nation ich bin im paradies
fischer seit zwölf jahren
komm holen schneidebrett dann schneide
ich dir wahnsinn oder so ich hab gedacht
ich brauche flugzeugträger sonst holen
sein
ein backofen habe ich auch noch porsche
porsche ist viva ostern kammer dann
locken sind meister zusammen und zog so
genial und nicht heuer wirklich gut neun
euro
vielleicht wachen zutaten mir hat mal
wahrscheinlich mal nicht mal und dann
hinzu
ich jetzt noch besser kommen lassen
können mit frisches brot nicht setzen
sich aber zum essen
tschüss
[Musik]